dans ce foyer l'électricité et rennes
pour fermer le volet regarder la
télévision
et quand il s'agit de cuisine et qui lie
à la haute comme autre appareil aussi
qui est pas mal énergivores on à la
plaque à induction à la cafetière une
machine à laver la vaisselle qui
fonctionne tous les jours et divers ce
robot si on compte les tester le gaz
annuel on est sur un budget de 1000 1100
euros comme toutes taxes comprises
à la fin de l'année ça fait quand même
un total c'est important à un budget
conséquent pour cette famille de deux
enfants dont l'épousé temps télétravail
alors lorsqu'alex michel a reçu dans sa
boîte aux lettres une proposition du
maire pour tenter de diminuer ses
factures il s'est lancé j'attends une
réelle une réelle économie
à une remise
au minimum de 200 euros annuels si si
c'est possible
est-ce que vous avez été au courant de
la l'opération des groupements d'achat
d'électricité de gaz de la ville
à l'origine de cette opération le maire
de chevigny saint sauveur kiala sa ble
ment parcourent les rues de sa ville de
11000 habitants pour fédérer le plus de
monde possible
plus on est nombreux plus on peut faire
des économies et donc à la fin du mois
on peut gagner 15 1% sur sa facture
d'électricité ou de gaz
les retours de formulaires s'accumulent
à la mairie une bonne centaine en une
semaine
je m'attendais pas à un tel engouement
et s'il ya un tel engouement
c'est parce que l'on touche à une
inquiétude réelle des gens qui ont du
mal à boucler les fins de mois alors
vous le voyez avant la crise du
coronavirus on va en voir de plus en
plus après il y en a qui sont dans le
rouge au 10 du mois le maire s'appuie
sur ce prestataire technique qui négocie
avec une cinquantaine d'opérateurs en
les mettant en concurrence
nous invitons les habitants les
entreprises du territoire à se
rassembler pour ensuite à la rencontre
des fournisseurs et leur dire nous ne
sommes pas tous seuls nous sommes
plusieurs centaines plusieurs milliers
fait de nous les meilleurs offres
possible avec cette démarche les foyers
pourront économiser entre 150 et 200
euros chaque année